all right another year another batch of
fifth grade head cases let's just get
through it I hope everyone's met our
class pets Leonardo and Squirtle I'm not
touching those things don't they eat
sleep and poo in the same place hey I
poo where he sleeps I
feel that lizard looks pretty
old do I look old thank you
no animal wants to be locked up I wasted
my life this year every student has to
take home a class pet this is my shot
are you
nuts so I go with these kids then I
escape and then I really
live it's
on ow mother of Godzilla what was that
you just spoke mom no you talk people
can't
no why are your hands wet they're
naturally
moist you're talking to them these kids
are all benefiting from my 74 years of
wisdom everyone thinks I'm weird kid
they don't even know you try doing
this
wait
[Music]
[Applause]
Leo first one usually it's in the front
but very nice you're growing up no no no
it's my
[Music]
dad what is so special about this
reptile you made me feel like I could do
anything it's going to end
bad she tough time but these are the
best years believe
me this is
[Music]
incredible